c'était référendum une arme à double
tranchant un documentaire de Pauline
pallier et Patrice Duhamel qui nous fait
l'honneur de participer à la Zone
d'Éducation documentaire bonjour vous
êtes journaliste vous avez débuté votre
carrière à l'ORTF puis vous êtes passé
par TF1 RMC la 5 vous avez dirigé France
Télévisions à vos côtés nous recevons
pas le Mauritz bonjour bonjour vous êtes
journaliste pour blast un site
d'informations indépendant vous réalisez
également des documentaires que l'on
retrouve sur spicy sur Blast évidemment
aussi et puis vous êtes la cofondatrice
du collectif mieux voté vous nous
expliquerez un petit peu plus tard ce
que vous défendez avec ce collectif
alors voilà pour les invités maintenant
les élèves bonjour
vous êtes la classe de
européenne du lycée Honoré de Balzac à
Paris alors vous avez vu le film
évidemment vous avez plein de questions
à poser à nos invités mais juste avant
j'aimerais savoir est-ce que vous aviez
déjà entendu parler de référendum avant
de voir ce film
oui dans les contextes des cours
d'histoire par exemple quand on parlait
de l'empire de napoléonien là le
référendum avait été utilisé ou sinon
plus récemment on a déjà entendu ce
terme
oui
en tout cas d'autres on avait déjà
entendu parler vous avez tous dit oui
bien sûr par exemple récemment avec le
brexit
[Musique]
les Anglais ont utilisé le référendum
pour sortir d'Europe pour sortir de
l'Europe
par une expression un adjectif c'est
quoi pour vous très en un mot en une
expression c'est quoi référendum quand
le gouvernement demande directement la
vie du peuple
un outil qu'on peut utiliser en
politique et qui tout double référendum
c'est soit on a ce qu'on veut soit on
l'a pas allez maintenant on passe à vos
questions et on commence avec toi Angèle
moi j'avais une question pour Patrice
Duhamel pourquoi est-ce que vous avez
choisi de faire un documentaire sur le
référendum
parce que c'était au moment de la
campagne présidentielle de 2022 et qui
avait beaucoup de candidats y compris le
président sortant qui a été réélu qui
soit disait je proposerai un référendum
si je suis élu de manière affirmative et
catégorique soit disait je pourrais ce
qui avait été le cas de d'Emmanuel
Macron je pourrais éventuellement sur
tel ou tel sujet organisé un référendum
comment choisissez-vous les intervenants
ou les intervenantes dans vos documents
parce que là en l'occurrence on avait le
choix
soit on prenait des politiques
et à ce moment-là ça devenait un jeu
politique un débat politique
le centre la droite l'extrême droite la
gauche radicale etc soit on faisait
appel à des experts entre guillemets et
c'est le choix qui a été fait avec des
spécialistes de la vie politique des
spécialistes des institutions des
historiens et des on a fait un mélange
voilà ce qui était sans doute plus
efficace parce que
n'ayant pas derrière pensé politique ou
politicienne disons réellement voilà
voilà ce qui s'est passé avant voilà
pourquoi
on utilise ou pas les référendum et
voilà ce qui peut se passer après
et vous comment est intéressant en fait
de revenir sur toute l'histoire du
référendum dans la 5e République
finalement ce référendum a été petit à
petit vidé de sa substance et que nos
votent plus pour des projets de loi mais
on vote pour dire oui ou non au chef de
l'État et c'est aujourd'hui ça qui
s'agirait de changer en fait il faudrait
complètement réformer ce qui est le
l'esprit même du référendum essayez de
dégager au maximum le référendum de la
figure du général de Gaulle qui continue
en fait à peser sur l'exercice cet
exercice démocratique qui devrait être
un exercice justement pour permettre aux
citoyens français de de pouvoir
participer en fait à la vie politique et
on voit que c'est une demande qui est de
plus en plus grande aujourd'hui mélodie
on t'écoute j'ai une question pour
Patrice Duhamel quel est le référendum
le plus marquant pour vous je pense que
celui de 2005 est très importante parce
que politiquement c'est sans doute le
moment et pourtant ça fait 18 ans
aujourd'hui mais c'est le moment où tous
les observateurs politiques et les
acteurs politiques ont mesurait
le fossé de plus en plus large entre ce
qu'on appelle le peuple entre guillemets
j'aime pas trop dire ça comme ça mais
c'est une expression que tout le monde
utilise et je mets aussi des je mets
aussi des guillemets et les élites par
ailleurs quelques mois plus tard il y a
eu un traité européen qui s'appelle le
traité de Lisbonne et qui est qui a
repris des éléments que les Français
avaient rejeté d'où cette espèce de
distance de cassure entre les électeurs
français et et la décision qu'ils
avaient prise et ce qui s'est passé par
la suite
pour moi ça a été un moment fondateur on
m'en parle encore aujourd'hui quand ça
m'arrive de donner des conférences sur
les questions démocratiques et ça a été
en fait ça ça accentué la défiance
démocratique en se disant si on va voter
et que on a envie de participer à la vie
publique et que notre avis n'est même
pas pris en compte et bien à quoi ça
sert en fait finalement en tant que
citoyen et citoyenne qu'on a évoqué
qu'on essaie de s'investir si le pouvoir
en place comprends pas en fait en compte
notre opinion on continue avec toi moi
j'ai une question qui est également pour
Patrice Duhamel c'est quels sont les
principaux objectifs que vous souhaitez
atteindre avec ce documentaire
très rapidement et très simplement
expliqué l'histoire des référendum
puisque c'était un sujet d'actualité qui
est d'ailleurs toujours un sujet
d'actualité et pour montrer comment il
était difficile
quand on est au sommet de l'État de
prendre des décisions en fonction de
toutes les informations
dont on dispose parce que
on voit bien que l'électorat encore une
fois ça a été dit et c'est l'évolution
de ces référendum dit oui ou non le plus
souvent au président de la République et
pas forcément le répond à la question
qui a été posée et que ce film soit vu
en l'occurrence par un public plus jeune
personne est majeur ici une personne a
encore voté officiellement est-ce que ça
faisait partie aussi peut-être de vos
objectifs ou pas du tout répondre tout à
fait
spontanément et sincèrement c'est c'est
l'objectif numéro un c'est pour essayer
de
d'expliquer aux Français et jeune moins
jeune très jeune qu'elle était
le contexte historique pour arriver à
pouvoir un sentiment un peu objectif
plus réaliste sur la situation
d'aujourd'hui
arrêter
c'est à ce moment que se font tous les
calculs qui permettront à partir de 300
bureaux de vote de savoir comment tous
les Français ont voté les Français ont
donc ratifié l'entrée de la
Grande-Bretagne et les trois autres
candidats dans le marché commun les
résultats du référendum ont toutefois
quelques peu déçus les partenaires de la
France notamment du fait des abstentions
monsieur Duhamel comment expliquer cette
augmentation du taux d'abstention lors
des différents référendum
alors d'abord enfin deux deux réponses
la première c'est que malheureusement il
y a une baisse de la participation
régulièrement y compris dans les
élections les plus importantes comme
l'élection présidentielle la deuxième
réponse c'est qu'il y a un certain
nombre de sujets soit qui n'intéresse
pas vraiment les Français parce qu'il
considèrent que c'est trop compliqué
soit et je prends l'exemple du
référendum de 2000 sur le passage du
septennat au quinquennat par ce goût
l'abstention a été absolument énorme je
suis 70%
extension de 70% parce que les Français
considéraient que la réponse était
connue d'avance cette question est cette
fois pour Madame Moritz c'est justement
avec toute cette question des années
plus récentes comment est-ce que vous
voyez la place du référendum dans notre
société aujourd'hui
alors je pense que le référendum tel
qu'il existe aujourd'hui en tout cas tel
qu'il est décrit dans le gouverne dans
le documentaire est amené soit à mourir
soit complètement se réinventer s'il
veut pouvoir continuer à exister
aujourd'hui en fait on voit que ça a
commencé un petit peu bougé donc on a le
référendum d'initiative partagée qui a
été mis en place par la réforme de 2008
donc c'est un référendum qui permet au
parlementaire de eux-mêmes déclencher
leur propre référendum sauf qu'en fait
c'est tellement compliqué d'arriver au
bout de cette procédure que pour le
moment il y a aucun référendum
d'initiative partagée qui est allé au
bout parce que pour ça en fait il faut
un cinquième des parlementaires donc ça
fait à peu près 185 ensuite il faut que
le Conseil constitutionnel valide la
proposition et enfin après il faut qu'il
y ait 10% du corps électoral qui votent
pour que ce référendum ait lieu donc il
faut en gros qui est 4,8 millions de
personnes pour vous donner un exemple
sur les référendums qui étaient contre
la privatisation de l'aéroport de Paris
il y a eu 1 million de signatures et
c'est le seul moment il y en a eu autant
donc en fait on voit bien que même le
référendum d'initiative partagée qui est
censé être une sorte d'innovation et
t'amener lui-même à se réinventer parce
que sinon on pourra jamais en fait avoir
de référendum qui soit déclenché par les
parlementaires et qui ne soit pas
déclenchés par le pouvoir en place
ensuite il y a aussi la possibilité de
faire des référendum d'initiative
citoyennes si vous avez suivi le
mouvement des gilets jaunes vous avez dû
voir plein de panneaux comme ça dans la
rue il y avait écrit Rick Rick voilà le
Rick c'est le référendum d'initiative
citoyenne et l'idée c'est de se dire
mais en fait cette fois c'est les
citoyens qui vont proposer eux-mêmes
directement en référendum sans passer
par les parlementaires sans passer par
le pouvoir en place et donc en fait
autour de ça il y a il y a des
initiatives assez intéressantes qui
proposent de dire pourquoi est-ce que on
mettrait pas en place une assemblée
citoyenne qui étudierait qui étudierait
au Québec qu'est-ce qui se passe si les
gens disent oui qu'est-ce qui se passe
si les gens disent NON et quelles vont
être les impacts de cette proposition de
loi sur la société et ensuite à partir
de là de soumettre un référendum de
faire un référendum auprès de la
population française mais de dire que
avant ça en fait on sait exactement
potentiellement qu'elles vont être les
impacts d'une proposition de loi moi je
voulais savoir si là dans le dans la vie
du lycée vous aviez l'occasion de voter
est-ce que vous participez par exemple
au Conseil de Vie Lycéenne oui Milo
je suis pas dans le conseil de villecres
mais on a
par exemple là récemment des votes qui
ont été faits sur le choix d'un logo
qu'on pourrait mettre sur des pulls
produits par le lycée c'est les logos
sont fournis et produits par des élèves
qui se portent volontaire et c'est les
élèves eux-mêmes qui votent pour ces
logos donc
je pense qu'on a l'occasion de voter
ici pour le coup c'est pour une chose
assez simple de voter pour un logo de
pull mais c'est toujours il y a toujours
un petit truc on se dit ouais j'ai donné
l'importance à ça voilà là en
l'occurrence pour un logo donc
vous avez peut-être voté pour d'autres
choses non les élections de délégués
vous avez voté POUR VOUS déléguer pour
vous échoder peut-être aussi
on a aussi des échos délégués qui
s'occupent parce que l'eau au lycée
Balzac on a des ruches d'abeilles où on
produit du miel et les échos délégués
ils s'occupent un peu de tout ça et on a
l'occasion de voter pour ça vous allez
voter dans deux ou trois ans c'est ça a
priori
si on vous pose la question vous vous
dites déjà tiens un référendum voilà la
question à laquelle j'aimerais bien
répondre et j'aimerais bien qu'on me
pose la question comme il est comme
électeurs aujourd'hui pour ou contre
l'expression des voitures à Paris
ça peut être un référendum aussi à Paris
tout à fait il y en a eu un qui était
organisé sur les trottinettes il y a
quelques semaines
exactement pour les énergies
renouvelables comme le solaire ou par
exemple je crois que ça existe aussi
pour l'énergie des marées aussi qui a
pas été mis en place je crois je sais
pas toi tu aimerais bien si tu avais la
possibilité de répondre à cette question
pour ou contre ça moi je serais pour par
exemple
l'énergie des marées
du ML est-ce que un référendum peut
porter sur tous les sujets de société
c'est une bonne question parce que non
c'est réglé par
l'article 11 de la de la Constitution
qui a été réformée CES 2008 c'est la
réforme de 2008 donc c'est soit
l'organisation des pouvoirs publics soit
les questions économiques sociales et
environnementales après vous avez un
énorme débat parce que par exemple
aujourd'hui je sais pas si c'est un
sujet qui vous passionne compte votre
âge mais peut-être que dans votre
famille il y a des gens qui vous en
parlent et qui sont concernés soit parce
que c'est leurs parents soient parce
qu'ils sont concernés eux-mêmes il y a
l'idée que il y a un débat actuellement
sur la fin de vie c'est à dire comment
on accompagne des gens qui souffrent
tellement qu'ils souhaiteraient pouvoir
se choisir eux-mêmes à quel moment et
sous quelle forme ils vont cesser de
vivre donc l'idée est que y est par
exemple un référendum sur ce sujet avec
une question qui est d'ailleurs
difficile à trouver ou des questions
c'est assez c'est un sujet qui devrait
qui devrait si ça le problème se pose
d'être réglé par le Conseil
constitutionnel peut-être pour vous
compreniez je vais très vite c'est
l'organisme suprême qui décide qui ce
qui est dans l'esprit et la lettre des
de la Constitution il y a neuf personnes
qui sont en général
plutôt en fin de carrière qui ont une
grande expérience c'est pour ça qu'on
les appelle les sages et il décide ce
qui est constitutionnel ce qui ne l'est
pas mélodie
et que le référendum c'est un outil plus
positif ou négatif
en fait c'est un peu comme n'importe
quel outil ça dépend complètement de ce
qu'on en fait ça peut être un outil
positif si c'est un outil qui permet de
justement recréer un lien entre les
citoyens et le pouvoir et en fait on
voit aujourd'hui et de plus en plus
notamment avec la réforme des retraites
que ce lien il est complètement brisé
qu'il y a en fait il y a plus de
confiance démocratique il y a une énorme
défiance et il y a cette impression en
fait que quoi qu'on dise quoi qu'on
fasse on n'est pas écouté on peut aller
marcher dans la rue on peut faire voilà
on peut faire des des grèves bah en fait
finalement le gouvernement va décider de
passer en force quoi qu'il se passe donc
je pense que ça peut être un outil
positif si il permet de reprendre le
pouvoir en fait sur des questions de
société et aussi de créer des débats de
société apaisés sur des questions qui
nous concernent toutes et tous mais ça
peut aussi être un outil qui va pas être
déclenché à certains moments ou trop
compliqué par exemple dans le cas de la
convention citoyenne pour le climat je
sais pas si on a entendu parler
justement il vient mais vous avez fait
le lien la convention citoyenne pour le
climat
ça vous parle vous en avez pas du tout
entendu parler en fait c'est un truc
assez fou l'idée c'était de prendre 150
citoyens tirés au sort qui était
complètement représentatifs de la
population française donc c'était
vraiment une mini-france donc il y avait
autant de jeunes que de vieux il y avait
des jeunes de 16 ans d'ailleurs que dans
la population française il y avait
autant d'Urbain que de ruraux il y avait
toutes les catégories
socioprofessionnelles représentées et
donc une mini-france qui allait se
pencher sur une question et de dire
comment est-ce qu'on peut réduire nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre d'au
moins 40% d'ici à 2030 dans un esprit de
justice sociale donc en gros sans que ça
pèse sur les plus démunis comme ça avait
été le cas avec la taxe carbone et donc
pendant 9 week-end on continue c'est 150
personnes elles ont vu des experts qui
sont venus leur expliquer bah ok c'est
quoi le problème avec le climat pourquoi
est-ce que pourquoi est-ce que la
planète se réchauffe qu'est-ce que ça
comme conséquence et plein de personnes
qui sont des parties prenantes de tous
ces problématiques aujourd'hui donc
aussi bien le patron de Renault qui
fabrique des voitures et des ONG qui
disent comme tu disais tout à l'heure il
faut réduire au maximum l'utilisation
des voitures à essence et à la fin de
tout ce processus ils ont formulé 149
propositions et c'était des propositions
qui étaient plus ambitieuses que aucun
gouvernement n'avait fait jusqu'à lors
donc c'était complètement inédit et le
problème qu'il y a eu après cette
convention citoyenne pour le climat
c'est que il y a eu un énorme travail de
décrypte détricotage de la part des
lobbies mais aussi de la part du
gouvernement ce qui fait que finalement
aujourd'hui il y a qu'une très petite
partie des mesures qui ont été
appliquées telles qu'elles avaient été
proposées par les citoyens et ce qui est
dommage en fait avec cette convention
citoyenne aussi c'est qu'on aurait pu à
la fin de cette convention citoyenne à
voir un référendum potentiellement à
choix multiple avec un certain nombre de
propositions vraiment
essentielles ou centrale qu'ils avaient
qu'ils avaient faites et permettre à
tous les Français de voter pour chacune
des propositions et de faire en sorte
qu'elle soit adoptée derrière quoi je
vais vous demander votre avis juste
après mais d'abord je voudrais connaître
le vôtre vous venez de découvrir de
comprendre ce que c'était que la
convention citoyenne l'idée c'est que
150 personnes qui réfléchissent ensemble
qui vont capter des informations qui
discutent entre elles
est-ce que qu'est-ce que vous pensez de
ça est-ce que est-ce que pour vous c'est
ce serait peut-être une bonne méthode
oui Milo oui je trouve parce que c'est
toujours bien quand il y a enfin
toujours bien la plupart du temps c'est
préférable lorsqu'il y a beaucoup de
personnes de milieu et d'avis différents
qui se rejoignent sur un seul et même
sujet parce que ça ouvre les discussions
personnellement je me dirais que ce
serait un mouvement vers l'avant plutôt
que vers l'arrière ce genre de procéder
ça pourrait permettre quand même à un
échantillon représentatif de donner son
avis et donc peut-être de relocaliser la
démocratie si je puis dire et de
permettre aux gens de donner un avis
plus représentatif que dans un pays où
en fait c'est enfin c'est très compliqué
d'entendre tout le monde ça peut être à
mon avis un moyen efficace est-ce que
finalement Paloma Moritz on n'est pas
aussi au bout de l'exercice du
référendum tel qu'on le connaît et tel
qu'on l'a vu dans le film de Patrice
Duhamel on est certainement au bout de
cet exercice mais aussi pour la simple
et bonne raison qu'il est totalement
binaire c'est à dire que de poser une
question et de dire et de demander de
répondre par oui ou par non ça n'a pas
vraiment de sens c'est à dire que si on
ne sait pas quels sont les implications
justement de cette question ou de ce
projet de loi s'il y a pas eu une
information préalable et puis surtout si
on n'a pas différentes options il y a de
plus en plus de propositions aujourd'hui
autour d'un préférendum par exemple
est-ce que vous pouvez nous l'expliquer
parce que c'est quelque chose que vous
défendez oui voilà en fait
ça vous parle
qu'est-ce que vous entendez qu'est-ce
que vous entendez
préférence préféré d'accord voilà
c'était pas moi c'est l'idée
c'est d'avoir plutôt que un référendum
avec une question et on répond oui non
c'est d'avoir un référendum à choix
multiple donc en fait on a plusieurs
propositions sur lesquelles on vote en
quelque sorte et en fait on peut le voir
par exemple sur des je sais pas si vous
aviez entendu parler des manifestations
contre l'aéroport de
Notre-Dame-des-Landes à l'époque qui a
aussi mené à une ZAD donc l'idée c'était
voilà il y a eu un référendum au niveau
local en disant est-ce que oui ou non il
faut un aéroport à Notre-Dame-des-Landes
et en fait c'est le genre de question
qui montre que c'est c'est pas ça qui
est intelligent et intéressant à poser
comme question la question c'est de dire
en fait aux personnes qui habitent sur
le territoire qu'est-ce que vous voulez
faire avec ce territoire et donc au lieu
de dire est-ce que vous êtes pour ou
contre un projet d'aéroport de dire bah
voilà genre plusieurs choses qu'on
pourrait faire avec ce avec ce
territoire je sais pas on pourrait créer
un centre culturel on pourrait faire un
aéroport on pourrait faire ci et chacun
vote en fait sur la proposition sur
chacune des propositions pour donner son
avis et en fait derrière ce qui est
intéressant c'est que quand on a un
référendum à choix multiple et bien les
personnes au pouvoir que ce soit au
niveau local ou au niveau national ben
elles vont pouvoir avoir une
photographie précise de l'opinion de ce
qu'elle pense sur un sujet donné et donc
ça leur permet aussi de prendre une
décision beaucoup plus éclairée
est-ce que ça vous parle ça je trouve
que dès qu'il y a plusieurs choix et dès
qu'on laisse l'option aux gens
d'exprimer une opinion un petit peu plus
diversifiée
c'est tout de suite plus intéressant
parce qu'on n'a pas comme vous l'avez
dit on n'a pas seulement une réponse sur
la question qui a été posée mais aussi
des informations supplémentaires qui
même si elles sont pas utiles ou
utiliser sur le moment pourront toujours
être récupérés plus tard où on pourra
toujours réfléchir en se disant ah oui
c'est vrai il y a un an on avait déjà
posé une question similaire ou on avait
déjà mentionné le sujet et on peut se
baser là-dessus pour créer d'autres
questions cette fois plus précise et
pour aller enfin pour rendre plus
efficace les questions futures ou les
décisions futures
album c'est beaucoup mieux parce que le
référendum c'est comme si on nous
demandait notre avis mais ça s'arrêtait
juste là c'est comme si la personne
l'avait déjà choisi la question et on
doit reprendre soit oui soit non alors
que le préférendum ça montre que
la personne même ne s'est pas exactement
ce qu'on veut il propose plusieurs trucs
et on doit donner notre avis dessus donc
c'est beaucoup mieux on est beaucoup
plus inclus dedans parce qu'avec le
collectif mieux voté le préférendum
est-ce que vous l'avez voilà est-ce que
vous en avez parlé autour de vous est-ce
que est-ce que c'est quelque chose qui
prend dites-nous un petit peu on vous en
êtes des étapes le plus gros en fait de
notre de notre plaidoyer c'est vraiment
sur le fait sur le jugement majoritaire
et sur le fait d'utiliser un autre mode
de scrutin que je majoritaire en fait
c'est un mode de scrutin qui plutôt qui
permet en fait plutôt que de voter juste
pour une personne ou un candidat de
voter pour l'ensemble des candidatures
en leur attribuant des mentions donc en
fait on va par exemple voter pour chaque
personne en leur attribuant des mentions
donc ça va de c'est à rejeter
insuffisant passable assez bien bien
très bien excellent et donc du coup la
personne qui élue à la fin c'est pas
celle qui a le plus grand nombre de voix
mais c'est celle qui a la meilleure
mention majoritaire donc en fait c'est
elle qui est la mieux évaluée par une
majorité de personnes donc ça change
complètement les choses parce que déjà
vous pouvez vous supprimer sur toutes
les candidatures parce que parfois je
sais pas même si vous votez pas
peut-être parfois quand vous regardez
les débats à la télé vous vous dites
j'ai un avis en fait sur la plupart des
candidats j'ai pas juste un avis sur une
personne donc vous pouvez donner cet
avis là et ça permet beaucoup plus
grandes liberté d'expression et encore
une fois ça permet aussi une
photographie de l'opinion beaucoup plus
précise sur justement soit des
candidatures donc dans le cadre d'une
élection mais soit aussi des
propositions et en fait on a de plus en
plus de partis politiques qui utilisent
le jugement majoritaire pour le vote
interne de plus en plus de profs au
lycée et dans les universités qui
l'utilisent pour des élections internes
et notamment les élections délégués de
classe et qui nous disent que c'est
hyper intéressant et que ça change
vachement la façon de voter ça vous
intéresserait
oui de dire ça j'aime bien ça j'aime
moins mais c'est intéressant quand même
et puis là vous avez compris le principe
qui serait pour ce cette méthode de vote
lever la main ouais
rajouter quelque chose oui moi je pense
qu'il faut impérativement rénover la vie
publique pas seulement la vie politique
présidentielle législative etc etc donc
ce que vous
présentez ce sur quoi vous travaillez je
trouve ça séduisant intellectuellement
la mise en œuvre pour certains scrutins
est assez compliqué parce que prenons
l'élection présidentielle donc vous
allez donner un certain nombre de
d'items vous allez dire ou de mention
non mais vous allez prendre des
objectifs
assez bien très bien excellent à rejeter
on priorise l'expérience plutôt que la
jeunesse ou la pensée
je privilégie l'expérience j'ai voté
pour cette personne
c'est ce que c'est ce que les candidats
et candidates décident de mettre en
avant pendant leur campagne
c'est hyper séduisant et je pense hyper
compliqué à mettre en œuvre en fait déjà
il y avait un moyen aujourd'hui nous on
a une application par exemple donc il y
a énormément de gens qui utilisent notre
application pour faire des votes où je
me majoritaires dans plein de situations
différentes et ça peut être aussi dans
leur vie personnelle pour choisir un
film par exemple que dans le cadre
associatif ou autre maintenant la
question c'est évidemment qu'on sait
bien que demain le prochain ou la
prochaine présidente de la République ne
sera pas élue au jugement majoritaire
mais en fait c'est des idées comme ça
qui permet de faire avancer les choses
ça peut être utilisé justement sur des
référendums au niveau local sur des
référendums à choix multiples ça peut
être utilisé à des à d'autres échelles
pour aussi créer d'autres rapports à la
démocratie et ça permet en fait de façon
générale de mettre en avant toutes les
options en fait les autres options qu'on
a justement pour avoir une démocratie
plus vivante quoi
quel est selon vous l'avenir du
référendum en France
un grand avenir
mais je pense que l'avenir du référendum
et dans sa l'innovation démocratique et
dans sa démocratisation et pour moi il
réside vraiment fondamentalement dans la
mise en place d'assemblées citoyennes
tirée au sort qui soit représentatif de
la population avec pourquoi pas aussi
des élus mais en tout cas de se dire que
on l'avenir du défuntom il est dans le
débat et il est dans le fait de lier
démocratie directe et démocratie
participative et démocratie
délibératives pour qu'il y ait un vrai
débat de société sur chacune des
questions qui peuvent être posées par
référendum qu'est-ce qui peut
réconcilier
Paloma les jeunes avec la politique par
exemple le vote à 16 ans moi je suis
assez favorable parce que je pense que
quand on donne une responsabilité bah
après derrière on se dit ah ouais
j'ai le droit de vote bah peut-être que
je vais aussi essayer de me renseigner
de savoir un peu ce qui se passe parce
qu'on fait cette confiance là donc moi
j'essaie d'être à la hauteur de cette
responsabilité et de cette confiance qui
a 16 ans déjà plus de 16 ans ah ouais
ça vous intéresse ou pas oui vous en
pensez quoi vous Patrice
militant du vote à 18 ans quand Giscard
a baissé le droit de vote de 21 à 18 ans
les Français étaient pas très n'était
pas très chaud et d'ailleurs les
électeurs de 18 à 21 ans ils ont
majoritairement voté contre lui dans les
élections présidentielles suivantes 180
ils ont majoritairement voté pour pour
Mitterrand non je rajouterais juste une
chose c'est que mais là ça passe pas par
la loi la Constitution les quotas etc
etc il faudrait que les partis
politiques fassent beaucoup plus
confiance aux jeunes notamment dans le
choix des candidats pour toutes les
élections locales nationales etc Ashley
on t'écoute est-ce que dans le futur les
référendums en ligne seront la norme
c'est très probable parce que justement
sur le référendum d'initiative partagée
quand on veut soutenir un référendum
d'initiative partagée aujourd'hui en
fait on doit le faire avec une pièce à
pièce d'identité son passeport ou sa
carte d'identité en ligne
donc
[Musique]
il y a des bornes aussi dans les mairies
mais c'est vrai que voilà le fait de
pouvoir le faire en ligne ça permet une
massification faut pas non plus
complètement oublier la fracture
numérique c'est à dire qu'il y a des
gens aujourd'hui qui ont pas accès voilà
qui ont pas accès Internet ou qui ont
accès à Internet genre en Edge en se
mettant sur une toile de leur maison
quoi et donc du coup il y a aussi une
nécessité de faire attention à ça et de
faire attention à cet accès d'où les
bornes mais moi je pense que c'est
plutôt intéressant parce que si on
vérifie bien aussi la sécurité parce que
ça ça va être aussi un des grands enjeux
des prochaines années la sécurité
numérique d'avoir du vote en ligne ça
permet aussi d'avoir un plus grand
nombre de personnes qui qui
potentiellement iront voter parce que
parfois c'est terrible mais par exemple
les jours où il fait très beau on se
rend compte que l'abstention est encore
plus importante parce que les gens ont
la flemme d'aller voter parce que voilà
ils vont faire autre chose et qu'ils
disent pour ça me faire perdre du temps
dans ma journée ensoleillée d'aller
voter enfin ça arrive il y a des pays où
on peut voter sur plusieurs jours
avoir une appli pour pour parler de
la démocratie de la citoyenneté de la
vie du lycée plus tard de la vie
politique des sujets qui vous
intéressent qui vous intéressent moins
aussi ça vous ça vous intéresserait
est-ce que vous pensez pour vous dans
quelques années que ce sera la norme je
pense que ça peut être intéressant parce
que ça nous forcerait à être plus
au courant de l'actualité et tout ça et
alors que si on a pas une appli on doit
faire l'effort de s'informer j'ai un
petit peu peur que ce soit fait de sorte
à ce que ça devienne
quelque chose d'un petit peu qu'on met
sur le côté c'est oh je vais aller sur
cette application il propose de voter
pour quelque chose donc je vote comme ça
et que ce soit fait un petit peu
à l'arrache
le cérémonial de la du vote dernière
question pour vous quel rôle en tant que
journaliste vous pouvez avoir dans la
vie politique et plus particulièrement
dans par exemple les référendum
journaliste politique je crois qu'il
faut pas suré-estimer le rôle parce que
c'est on a toujours tendance à penser
que ce sont les médias qui font les
élections je vous ai donné l'exemple de
2005 tout à l'heure les médias étaient
très majoritairement favorable oui sur
le nouveau traité européen et ça a été
massivement rejeté par les Français donc
tout simplement
éclairer le choix par des explications
de contexte notamment des exemples
étrangers etc
deuxièmement
essayer de faire remonter le maximum
d'informations et donc de créer des
émissions ou les français et notamment
les jeunes peuvent s'exprimer de manière
la plus ouverte la plus directe la plus
spontanée et la plus réaliste possible
et troisièmement sur des sur des enjeux
de société
essayer
c'est un peu aveupieux parce que je
crois que c'est très difficile de
dépolitiser pour faire en sorte que ça
soit le moins partisan possible partisan
au sens politicien de du terme voilà
voilà ce que je dirais merci infiniment
à tous les deux d'avoir répondu à toutes
vos questions bravo vous pouvez vous
applaudir exactement bravo l'émission
est déjà terminée bravo à votre
professeur aussi qui vous a si bien
préparé alors nous on se retrouve
évidemment très vite avec un nouveau
film et un nouveau documentaire parce
qu'il n'y a pas d'âge pour questionner
le monde et ces images allez salut
[Musique]